اهلا وسهلا الراوي اهلا سمر تحيه طيبه
لكما ولجميع المشاهدين صباح العربيه نعم
الصوت والصوره اليوم من هنا من قريه
المسقي الاثريه التاريخيه التي يعد عمرها
من 1700 عام الى 2000 عام وهي تعتبر من
اقدم القرى التاريخيه هناك في جنوب
السعوديه اترككم الى معزم الاعصاب من الخط
صوره وجوله حول هذه المنطقه التاريخيه
التي يزيد عمرها عن 1700 عام تتواجد في
هذه القريه اكثر من 450 منزلا 140 منزلا
منها كانت ماهوله بالسكان الى وقت قريب
وهي تعتبر اليوم من اقدم القرى السياحيه
الاثريه نتحدث اليوم عن الدمج بين الاثر
التاريخي العظيم ايضا الطابعه الحضري
الحديث في خارج اسوار هذه القريه
التاريخيه نتحدث اليوم اذا عن انها كانت
جسرى تجاري جسم تجاري طويل جدا ممتد بين
الشام ومكه والمدينه واليمن وكانت تحمل
اول سوق في جنوب السعوديه نتحدث عن ان
قوافل العرب كانت تمر من هذا السوق
لايصال البضائع الى جنوب السعوديه وايضا
لايصال القوافل وحملها الى مكه والمدينه
وبلاد الشام نتحدث اليوم ايضا ان هذه
القريه خلال هذه الايام وخلال هذه الاعوام
ايضا تشهد تطورا كبيرا من خلال اعاده
تهياتها ووضعها مناسبه للسياحه بشكل اوسع
عبر تهيئتها واحيائها بالعديد من المقاهي
والمطاعم والجلسات التاريخيه والمناطق
التي ستقام فيها جلسات ادبيه
وامسيات شعريه لاثراء التجربه الكبيره
للسائح حينما يصل الى هذه المنطقه تعتبر
قريه المسقي من اقدم القرى التاريخيه في
السعوديه وتعتبر اقدم قريه تاريخيه تحمل
كم هائل من البيوت الاثريه والمنازل وايضا
الاسواق التجاريه في جنوب السعوديه كنا قد
مررنا ايضا هنا من خلال عدد من المداخل
تحوي اربعه مداخل اطول مدخل فيها يصل طوله
الى اكثر من 400 متر كان يمر من خلال
السكان هذه القريه ويذهبون لقضاء
احتياجاتهم وايضا لشراء الحاجيات من
الاسواق القريبه هنا نتحدث اليوم عن اكثر
من سبعه واربعين محل تجاري كانت متواجده
في هذه القريه ويعتبر عدد كبير جدا مقارنه
بالحركه التجاريه السابقه شهدت هذه القريه
عوائل كبيره جدا وصلت الى هنا واستقرت
واحيت الحركه التجاريه والحركه السياحيه
الكبرى اليوم مع موسم صيف عصير 2023 تم
اعاده تهيئه بعض المناطق التاريخيه هنا في
قريه المسقي والمناطق المحيطه بها حينما
يصل السائح اليوم الى عصير تكون قريه
المسقي بالتاكيد اهتماماته لزيارتها
والتعرف على هذه المنطقه التاريخيه التي
تحمله ارثا عظيما وكبيرا جدا هناك ايضا
المساجد تم اعاده تهنئه هناك بعض
المسابقات الطعام تتم هناك او المطاعم
مسابقات الها خاص بالمطاعم والطعام
والتذوق الطعام
تحدث في هذه المناطق اليوم بالسعوديه هل
هذه بنفس المنطقه يعني هل هناك مطاعم هل
هي مختومه هل هناك فنادق يمكن بالقرب منها
طبعا قريه المسقي تقع في الشرق مدينه عسير
في ابها بالتحديد ولكن نتحدث عن نعم تحوي
عدد من المطاعم القاه لكن ليست بتلك
الكثره لانها منطقه سياحيه اكثر لكن مع
المشروع الجديد في مشروع تطوير المناطق
التاريخيه والاثريه سيتم تزويدها واحياها
بالعديد من المقاهي والمطاعم وكما اسقطت
الجلسات التي ستمارس فيها الكثير من
الفعاليات والانشطه لاثراء تجربه السائحه
الساحه حينما ياتي الى هنا يجد عمرا
تاريخيا طويلا لهذه القريه ويجد ايضا عمقا
تاريخيا عظيما وتاريخيا طبعا بالمناسبه
قريه المسقي ذكرت من احدى القرى الظواهر
في القران الكريم في سوره سبا وهي تعتبر
اقدم القرى في التاريخ وتم اكتشافها قبل
تقريبا 300 عام قبل الهجره النبويه تحدث
ايضا يوم انها تعتبر قريه اصبحت مزارا
سياحيا كبيره جدا هنا
اسامه جميله جدا
وانت ما شاء الله عليك منطلق في الحديث
بشكرك جزيل الشكر اسامه القاسم مراسل صباح
العربيه شكرا شكرا لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات